c'est qu'ils soient auteurs qui vous
fait tribal mois en gars en ce moment
non tient bien et stromae curieusement
victoire la jeune coiffeuse à l'essai
mais non mon poste non mais tu sais très
bien que vous pourriez pécho mais
puisque à l'épée chose m'en fous
personne folie oui parfois les ai chanté
avec le audiard et à l'été pourri ce que
ce qu'ils sont venus chanter ça leur a
fait faire un nom mais sera pas leurs
fins ils adorent écouter alesi bas c'est
quoi mais je sais pas le faire je vous
dis allez-y mois contrairement à lui je
connais mes limites
ah d'accord non mais non mais un mec que
vous aimeriez pécho même un chanteur
mais mort sinatra il est mort il est
mort
m
la mère a ouais on m'avait dit que
j'avais la même voie que frank sinatra
ben ça fait combien épouse coup de
gueule